hi my name is Gina Odierno i'm a student
deacon here and a graduate student at
the School of Drama welcome to my
nightmare public speaking I know what
you must be thinking School of Drama um
I work backstage so it's okay but
standing here in front of a group of
people no matter how well loved is
terrifying to me if you don't know
there's actually no oxygen right here
and I know that my science friends are
gonna disagree and say that that's not
actually possible but air does not get
into my lungs when I'm here so as
possible there's no oxygen so the
leadership of this church has been so
fantastic also about saying if you don't
want to read this thing or if you don't
want to speak it's okay and I'm sure
they were really surprised I'm like no
let me speak because I freaked out and
then I get big hands because I'm Italian
but um so I don't know why it is that I
freaked out about public speaking it has
nothing to do with maintaining some
picture of perfection that I can't live
up to because that ship has sailed i
have stumbled over every word in the
dictionary i have announced that of
prayers to be read together in the
middle of the prayer i have done it all
so it's not really about that you know
those notable blunders I've even
introduced myself as hi I'm Gina I'm
whatever as Rob reminds me from my first
year so no it is not about yeah I didn't
want to cry by the way so I'm trying to
be funny but um yeah and I put print
aticle citations inside my senses okay
so and I think it's important actually
to know your boundaries but um you know
and you might ask myself oh so if this
is a boundary public speaking is a
boundary for me I can't even look up at
the audience in front of me why am i
speaking in front of this audience and
it's simple actually is that boundaries
for me aren't the place where I find it
and say okay I can sit inside here
because if I did that I would be in a
goldfish bowl there are a lot of
boundaries we all have these little itty
bitty hang-ups that if we tried to serve
them all we would get know where we
would be free willy with it like droopy
little fin on the top you know um and
I'm not contented for that I want to see
what's in the ocean
no so here I am speaking in front of you
guys uh so and you know I have to ask
myself like what could go wrong it's not
like some life-altering Lee bad thing is
gonna happen because I'm up here
speaking me this like awkward clumsy me
I'm just here I'm just doing it it
happens I'm speaking it's great and
that's one of the many reasons why i
love the university church is it's a
safe place to kind of press those
boundaries talking to people is really
difficult to me also i'm theatre weird I
know but um coffee hour is one of the
most terrifying places in this church to
me even the little catacombs downstairs
cannot you know match that but um so let
me get back to my script so I mean what
I try to do is find those boundaries but
instead of hitting against them reach
out and explore further find what it is
that's like that weird little gritty
place that I found and you know it's
enabled me to have these great
relationships and friendships and
conversations and meals and you know
service projects and you know if I you
know just serve that horribly awkward
feeling of oh no if I talk to these
people then they're gonna know i'm weird
you know i'm weird i'm always here you
know that i'm weird so um but you know
as I wouldn't have these experiences I
mean you know out on the green I would
not talk to those neighbors of mine who
are you know experiencing homelessness I
wouldn't have talked to the gentleman at
Abraham's tent like these are
experiences have enriched me and if I
fed that like little place then I
wouldn't be anywhere so no Free Willy
mode for me but I don't think that this
exploration of boundaries or what's
beyond them really ends with speaking in
front of a crowd or even with how I
relate to the world I think it extends
into my faith last year I read a book by
Rob Bell called Velvet Elvis repainting
of the Christian faith and yeah Velvet
Elvis right um and it fits up there with
like my happy hippy dippy version of
Christianity because that's how I fit in
the world and I don't really know how to
explain myself because I'm I used to be
catholic like what is that you know all
I knew about Protestant for I came
here was they ended shakespearean
theater so I had a collect little 400
years of lack of knowledge which Ethan
has thankfully caught me up on so like
if all you knew about Catholics was the
Inquisition that'd be bad too so um but
what he says in here he talks about
jumping on a trampoline with his sons
and I don't know if any of you guys have
had the great pleasure of jumping on a
trampoline but it is fantastic and it is
impossible it's just like stretchy
little fabric and got a little Springs
all around and you like fly higher than
you could ever do it under your own
power and what he is impossible really
like you're flying you're human and
you're flying and what he says about
these idea is it's not sure your faith
can be like a trampoline he says in fact
it's the stretch and the flex that makes
it so effective it's firmly attached to
the frame and the mat yet you have room
to move it has brought a fuller deeper
richer understanding to the mysterious
being who is God he says that these
these Springs they're not you know fixed
the springs are our you know our ideas
and you know what we think about the
spring isn't God is just how we
understand God in our world so you could
take it out you can stretch it expand it
and put it in and that's one thing
that's so great about this church is
that we can take a little element out
look at it and explore it and say oh
that's we just called God her I got a
little weirded out you know and there's
nothing wrong with that it's you know
it's that that's for someone and maybe
it's not for me but it's okay because
this space you can stretch and you can
grow and you can try things because
we're ecumenical and we sing in Pakistan
I don't even know what some of those
words are thank God for the you know
little translation at the bottom I would
sing it anyways because I'm game but you
know that's what you have to do so I
think what I would say kind of enclosing
is I am now off to oblivion I am a
freelance stage manager I work in the
arts I have two months of work at a
hundred and fifty dollars a week if you
do the math that is not a new york
apartment but you know i have spent
three years stretching and growing and
finding these boundaries and expanding
and what i would like to challenge this
community that I so love and that I have
so enjoyed for these three years is not
be fearless because that is not possible
you are going to have fear what I ask
you to do is to be courageous in the
face of that fear so whether that fear
is we just said God was a girl or Ono I
have to make bread and I have never made
bread before whatever it is just do it
just try don't be held back by fear and
embrace the fear it's there you can't do
anything about it but then you know get
out of it your way and just live so
that's what I had to say a lot faster
than I practiced so thank you very much
by one of my favorite things about these
reflections is always how much they
truly do reflect the person who's
speaking so certainly mine will be very
different a little more serious than
genius thank you all for the opportunity
to speak today about my time at Yale and
here at the University church I really
can hardly believe that it's my turn to
speak for graduation but here we go a
little about me first I've been here at
Yale for about four and a half years
studying in the chemistry department and
last week I turned in my dissertation
that's the end of chemistry for now
luckily I've also been a part of this
community for more than half of that
time and with my address i want to tell
you how I came to be here what I love
about this place and maybe a few words
of advice if you can call it that and i
should say i wanted to specifically say
this this is not goodbye because i'm not
ready for goodbye certainly i'll be
around until i leave on May twenty-third
but we can leave goodbye for another day
so before I came to yell I think it
would be fair to say that I had lost my
faith lost my faith in worship lost my
faith in church lost my faith in faith
but soon after being at Yale for a year
so it was clear that I was just lost
just then my friend Dan Tyler and I were
talking about the university church one
evening when I saw one of one of these
on his kitchen
cabinet in 2009 and after coming here
and getting involved a little by little
eventually joined the deacons and had
the great privilege of helping to lead
this place which is complex and
beautiful just look at our mission
statement today's jeremiah reading
seemed especially fitting for me for
this occasion my favorite line says no
longer shall they teach one another or
say to each other no the lord for they
shall all know me no longer teach that's
right no need to pass on information in
weak human forms it seems since the new
covenant with god was written on their
hearts as an academic and now being
amongst academics this idea shocked me a
little bit when i read it earlier this
week how amazing to know something
without needing to be taught and for it
to be about something as profound as the
divine but then i thought about my
personal faith journey as i mentioned a
moment ago when i arrived here at the
university church even though i had
grown up as a person of faith i was
spiritually lost there could be no
greater difference between the person
that i was then and the person that I am
now and I realized as I pondered those
lines from Jeremiah that the way things
changed for me was in no small part by
coming here to batao of course I'm
thankful for this beautiful space and
our wonderful University which has the
foresight and wisdom to let us take part
in this great experiment of an
ecumenical christian community in the
midst of the Yale moreover the words we
speak in this place have been a great
comfort to me but more than either words
or walls it is all of you my friends
mentors and colleagues in the audience
here that have made my faith in life
over the past few years how do I know
the Lord these days it is through all of
you
through all your good works at Columbus
house and all around New Haven through
the robust discussions amongst Deacons
about how to use our limited offerings
to do these important works around new
haven in the world through a sly smile
thrown in someone's direction casually
during worship through our rowdy
conversation before after and sometimes
during worship through our traditions
our closing words from Micah are ever
varying prayers before communion and
even though it's a small thing the
exhortation that we hear each Sunday as
we did today to participate in whatever
way you feel comfortable and I know the
Lord through your kindness to me I shall
miss all of you in this community so
very much is without words to be
expressed I leave knowing the face of
the divine and with the warmth and
courage that each of you have taught me
my journey and all of yours will surely
bring us together again one day and
we'll tell stories of the wonderful
things we've done after battelle and of
course stories about what we did here
together thank you all so much I am
humbled and blessed to have shared his
space with you and in closing I wanted
to read a quote from Lucretius which
I've been finding inspirational since I
was working on my dissertation but those
watchful sentinels Sun and Moon
travelling with their light around the
great revolving region of heaven have
taught min well that the seasons of the
year come round and that all is done on
a fixed plan and in fixed order if
things sometimes feel as if there's a
fixed plan in a fixed order it must be
partially due to the reassuring the
reassurance of knowing our Lord and each
of you whatever life throws at me i will
take reassurance about the path forward
from my experiences in this place and i
hope that you can and will do the same
if we trust him no matter what path were
on I truly believe that God will tell us
that there is a good path there and we
are always on it sometimes I'm tempted
to disobey the last part the command to
walk out of a fear of doing anything at
all I love new notebooks always pains me
to write the first line but notebooks
are meant to be used and life is meant
to be lived so now when I get something
new the first thing I do is scratch it I
tear a page a dirty it up a bit it
reassures me that there was a good path
through imperfection there is a future
in every direction all of us are on a
right path just because it's the path
that we're on and so it's the one that
God is on as well so we should walk in
it because God doesn't meet us where we
are God already is where we are and when
that voice of reassurance is hard to
hear let us be that voice for each other
let us learn to love each other so that
we can learn how to be loved so was I
and we all really prepared to go out and
make it all up as we go along I want to
leave this beautiful 4 verse with you so
that you all may know that you're okay
that you what we have to offer is
acceptable that you have a brilliant
future to look forward to so remember
whether you turn to the right or to the
left your ears will hear a voice behind
you saying this is the way